All right.
So just a couple of
announcements real quick.
Can you guys turn this
down a little bit?
So, for tomorrow,
you guys should all
be ready to give these short
presentations on your design
projects in recitation.
We posted a one-page
guide talking
about what it is that you should
prepare for next time in class.
These are short presentation.
You shouldn't need to put too
much time into getting them
together, but please
look at the Web page
if you're not sure of
what it is that you're
supposed to be doing in class.
Today what we're
going to do is wrap up
our discussion of security.
And what I want
to do is start off
with a fun little
diversion which
is over the past couple of times
that you guys were in class
we captured a log of all
of the network traffic
that was going on while people
were in class on their laptops.
And, for the most
part, it turned out
that you guys were
pretty boring.
Nobody was actually
doing anything exciting,
but there were a couple
of interesting lessons.
In case you're curious as
to what we actually did,
we ran this TCP dump command.
The pseudo command just
says run this command
as though you are a super
user, as though you are SU.
And then TCP dump just says
dump out all the traffic
on the specific
network interface.
In this case, it is
dumping out all the traffic
on EN1 which on this computer
is the wireless network.
So we are just dumping out
all of the packets that
were sent out over EM1.
And what you see here
is the yellow part
is the sort of header of the
packet saying this is an IP
packet and specifying who
the destination and recipient
of this packet are.
And then there is some body
text, some sort of payload that
is associated with this packet.
In this case, this first
packet is some binary data.
We cannot make any sense of
it, but if you look at some
of these other
packets, for example,
this is a packet which is
an HTTP request packet.
What you see is that there,
in fact, is English text.
The HTTP protocol uses English
text to transmit information,
and so this is specifying
some information
about this is the actual
HTTP request going out.
In this case, it was going
out from this laptop.
I just set this up as to
illustrate what TCP dump does.
We ran a command like this
while you guys where in class
and captured a trace
of what you were doing.
And we ran a little
Perl script that
went through this
trace of packets
and sucked out all the
Web pages that you guys
had been looking at.
And so I have pictures
of some of the Web pages.
A lot of it, as I
said, is pretty boring.
There is somebody who is looking
to buy a micro drive so they
searched for Micro Center
cruiser USB high-speed
on Google.
We saw this page
coming back from Google
which was the search request.
And, in fact, you sort
of poke around some more
and see this person actually
found the Micro Center Website
and went to Micro
Center and apparently
was trying to
purchase this thing.
There were also a
couple of people
looking for movies, people
who were looking for a movie
to see.
In fact, we actually
saw this on both days.
It wasn't just one
day that somebody
was looking for movies, but
somebody keeps coming to class
and looking for movies.
The next one, though, is
much more interesting.
There are a couple
of Web pages where
somebody is looking at a
tool called Gaim-Encryption.
Gaim is the open source AOL
Instant Messenger client,
and Gaim-Encryption is a
version of the open source Gaim
client that encrypts
data that gets
transmitted over the network.
And the way it works is when you
install this tool it generates
you a public/private key pair.
And then, when you have a
chat session with somebody
else who is also using
this Gaim-Encryption tool,
it sends that person
your public key
and then it uses public/private
key encryption and signing
in order to protect information
that gets transmitted
over the network.
So there was somebody
who, during class,
was looking at this tool.
We see they go to the
project page, sourceforge,
where this tool is hosted.
And they are clicking around
looking at what the tool does
and reading about it.
And then you see that
they download this tool.
And, in fact, after
that, at some point,
there is a whole lot of AOL
Instant Messenger traffic
that is going out
on the network.
I am just surmising that
this traffic actually
belongs to this person
who downloaded this tool.
And you can see that, in fact,
the tool appears to be working.
So this traffic is
not intelligible.
And, in other cases, when
you see this tool actually
goes across the
network in plain text,
the Gaim normally
runs in plain text
and you can just see the
entire transcript of the chat
happening if you run this tool.
There is a very interesting
security lesson here
which is that sometime later,
in this particular trace
of a chat, we see
this same person.
Person one, their name is
transmitted in plain text.
You see this same person even
when using the Gaim tool.
You don't see their
messages in plain text,
but you see this
person now actually
is talking, having
a conversation.
And they sort of say oh,
I download this Gaim tool,
now I can talk encrypted
to other people.
And yet there is
this conversation
where it is not encrypted, and
this sort of dialogue goes on.
They are talking about
somebody who is in class
and say why doesn't this
person go to class anymore?
And they are having this little
chat session back and forth
about why this person
isn't in class.
And the dialogue goes on talking
about their design project
and they're worried about it.
It is sort of a nice
example of a security
problem or a potential
security problem,
which is that this person
actually did something
that was sort of nice.
They came to
security class, they
are learning about
security in class,
they go download
this tool and think,
OK, I've got this tool installed
and now my conversations
are protected.
And then, as soon
as they try and talk
to somebody who
isn't also running
this version of the
tool, their conversations
are no longer protected anymore.
This is sort of a nice example
of why security is actually
a really hard
thing to get right.
Because this person
may have even believed
that this person
they were talking
to had this tool
installed as well,
but you sort of don't know
that it is not working
until somebody points out
that it is not working,
somebody violates,
goes in and is
able to access this
on unprotected data.
This is a nice example
of why security is hard
and why sort of
providing protection
is essentially a negative role.
You never really
know that you are
protected until somebody points
out that you are not protected.
That was sort of a little
lesson about security,
and I hope that it sort of
pointing out a reason in which
why it is that
security is something
that is both difficult
and something that you
might want to be conscious of.
Often times when you're sitting
there using your laptop,
you have this perception that
is my information I am sending,
nobody is going to be able
to overhear this information.
It is going so fast and being
transmitted so instantly
that, of course, I am private.
You feel very sort
of isolated when
you're having this communication
until somebody points out
that it is actually
very easy, I mean
this is a tool that is standard
on all Linux distributions.
And it is one line that
we type into our computer
to get this information.
It is actually very
easy to do this,
so it is something that
when you are transmitting
sensitive information out
over the network over an email
or in an Instant Messenger you
might want to actually think
about whether or not
you want to be sending
this information out in the
way that you're sending it out.
What I want to do now is come
back to something we were
talking about last time, finish
up our discussion a little bit
of authorization and then talk
about how we can start thinking
about designing protocols
that actually provide --
How we can reason
about these security
protocols that we are using.
In particular, how we can reason
about authentication protocols
within networks.
If you remember
last time, we talked
about this idea of building up
a secure communication channel
and then we talked about
doing authorization
on top of that channel.
Remember, authorization
is this process
of determining whether a
given user should have access
to a particular resource
that they want access to.
We talked about
two main techniques
for doing this,
ACLs and tickets.
An ACL is an access
control list which
is just a list of users who
are authorized to access
a particular resource.
And so the way
typically an access
control list works is that
the system first authenticates
the user to determine
what their identify is
and then it checks to see
whether that identity is
actually on this
access control list
and the user is authorized to
access this particular resource
they want access to.
Now, ticket has a
slightly different flavor
which is typically
if a user presents
a ticket you do not need
to actually check and see
what their identity is.
Simply having the ticket is
sufficient to allow somebody
to have access to a resource.
The analogy here is very
similar to a physical ticket
in the real world.
You go to a concert,
you hand them a ticket
and they let you
into the concert
without checking your ID.
A common example of a
ticket in the real world
is on the Web you get these
cookies which are like tickets.
And the reason you
use cookies instead
of checking access
control list every time is
that when you have
a particular cookie
the system doesn't have to
re-authenticate you in order
to allow you to have access
to the system every time
you revisit a page.
I have a cookie
for Amazon dot com
on my computer when I am in
the process of purchasing
some item from Amazon
dot com that identified
my identity and my
shopping cart and I
don't have to sort of re-log
in every time I request
a new secure page from Amazon.
Specifically, what we are
talking about is the Web.
And we had a browser
and a Web server.
And the browser
and the Web server
were talking over one of these
secure communication channels.
And we said this channel
has both been authenticated
and is confidential.
Authorization, we said,
happens where there is
some guard process in charge.
This is our guard.
And it sits in front of
the services on the system.
When a request comes
in to access a service,
the Web server
passes that request
onto the guard module which
does the authorization.
And then, if the
request is authorized,
it goes ahead and passes
it onto the service.
We talked about this
notion of how we establish
a secure communication channel.
Typically, we do
that by exchanging,
one way that we talk about doing
this is where B, for example,
would discover W's public
key somehow and then use
that public key in order
to exchange with W a shared
secret key that they
could use to encrypt
all their communication.
I will show that protocol again
in a minute, but the question,
and the question that we are
really going to get at today,
we want to focus in more
on this question of how
it is that B actually
discovers W's
public key in a
public key system
and how it is that B
can convince itself
that, in fact, it is actually
talking with this service W.
If B wants to have a
conversation with Amazon dot
com, how does it
actually convince itself
that this public key that it
has, in fact, belongs to Amazon
dot com and that it
is actually having
a conversation with Amazon dot
com instead of with somebody
else who is pretending
to be Amazon
dot com or has lied about
Amazon dot com's public key
so that it can overhear
Amazon dot com's traffic.
We are going to focus
in more on that now.
Let's look at this simplified
version of an authentication
protocol.
This is going to be like
the Denning-Sacco Protocol
that I showed with
the broken example
or like SSL, for example, on
the Internet also sort of works
roughly in this way.
We've got our browser,
we've got our Web server
and we've got some
certificate authority.
This is the kind of
picture we drew before.
We said the browser sends
to the certificate authority
a request for, say,
the public key of W.
The certificate authority
sends a message back
with has the certificate for
B and the certificate for W.
And these are
simply signed things
that the certificate
authority has
signed that include the public
key for B and W in them,
so that is all certificates are.
And then B sends a message to W.
And there is some trickiness
in getting this message right,
but this message basically is
a signed and encrypted message
that tells W that it
would like to initiate
a conversation with it.
And perhaps it
proposes a shared key
that it can use in
that conversation.
It is a little bit tricky to
actually figure out and make
sure we get the format
of that message right,
and that was there is bug with
the Denning-Sacco Protocol,
but you get the idea.
So W then sends a message back
saying perhaps asking user
to go ahead and trying to
authorize the user saying,
OK, I agree that that is the
key, now what is your name
and what is your
password, for example.
And then, once it has exchanged
that name and password,
B is allowed to log into the
system and access whatever
these resources B should
have access to on the server.
The question that
I want to focus on
is this question
about how B actually
decides the certificate
authority that it should trust.
How does B initially establish
the sort of authenticity
of the certificate authority?
When we talked
about authentication
before, we presented this
model that was sort of, well,
you are going to decide that you
trust somebody by, for example,
having a conversation with the.
I am going to run
into you in the hall
and you're going to
say my public key is X,
and then I am going
to be able to have
a conversation with you.
But, clearly, that
is not what happens
in the case of the Internet.
For example, on the
Internet, I do not
have to call up Amazon dot
com or call up my certificate
authority and get the
certificate authority's
public key from them.
Somehow I have already
gotten this thing.
And so we sort of want
to think about how
it is that we can actually
exchange these keys
and how it is that these systems
can actually decide that they
trust each other and that they
are willing to authenticate
each other.
To do that, what
we are going to do
is look at something called
authentication logic.
The specific version
of authentication logic
we are going to talk about is
something called BAN logic.
B, A and N just stand for
the names of the three people
who proposed this thing so it
is not a specific acronym you
need to know.
And so what authentication
logic is going to do
is allow us to reason
about these protocols
for deciding whether
or not we actually
trust something like a
given certificate authority.
Just to think about
this a little bit more,
let's look at a
specific example.
Suppose that you receive a
message over the Internet.
Suppose this message
says it is some message m
and the message says sign
is signed m with some key k,
call it k sub A.
And suppose that the
contents of message m are m
equals give A your
credit card number.
This might be a valid request.
We might be purchasing
something from Amazon dot com.
In that case, you might
think it might be OK,
we might expect to receive
a request like this.
So this thing was signed
with kA and the message
said give A your
credit card number,
but how do we actually know,
you know, maybe A, in this case,
is give to Amazon dot
com and we know that we
are talking to Amazon dot com.
And so if this, in fact,
were an authentic message,
we might be actually willing
to give Amazon our credit card
number.
How do we actually know,
though, that this message,
that kA is the key that
belongs to Amazon dot com?
We want to answer the
question how do we
know that or trust that kA, we
are going to say, speaks for A?
This notation speaks
for just means
that if we see something that,
for example, is signed with kA
that claims to be from A, we
might actually trust, in fact,
that this thing came from A.
And we want to
sort of determine,
we are going to try and
answer the question of how
do we trust this?
One way that we might trust
this is true is if we had heard,
for example, some message,
let's call it m2 -- --
from somebody B that
had said that --
Or this message
said kA is A's key.
One way that we might start
thinking about, one way that we
might trust A is if we had
heard from somebody else
or heard from some other
place that kA was A's key.
But now this is kind
of a slippery slope
because now you say
the question, well,
how did you determine
that you trust B's key?
There is sort of
this infinite process
that you could end
up going through.
And that doesn't sound
like a very good idea.
One way in which
sort of we might
bottom out this
recursion, we might
end this sort of infinite
process of collecting
keys is if we actually sort
of, in the example I gave you,
heard from one
person at some point
suppose there is a B and
a C and D and E and an F.
And then eventually we get to F.
F is our friend who
we had talked to,
and F had said my public
key is this and here is
the public keys for a
few people that I know.
So you might trust
F and you might
believe that F knows
a few other people.
And then those
people who F knows
might in turn know
a few other people.
And eventually we might
be able to sort of
have this web of inner connected
people all of whom we trust.
So this would be sort
of a "web of trust".
We might be able to build
up a web of trust like this,
but you could imagine that
these relationships are
pretty complicated.
For example, B might
trust a few people
and C might trust a few people
and D might trust a few people.
And, every time we're
presented with some message,
we need to have some sort of
principled way of thinking
about whether we have
a set of these keys,
for example, that
actually allow us
to decide whether we
should accept this message
or believe this message or not.
If we had a web of
trust like this,
we would need some way of going
about validating or verifying
that, in fact, these messages
were messages we should trust.
That is what authentication
logic is really all about.
This is the
simplified band logic
that is presented in the text.
It is on page 11-85.
If you want to copy it
down, I will try and leave
time for you, but in case
you want to just copy it out
of the text you might not need
to worry about copying down
the exact logic here.
There are three rules in this
simplified authentication logic
and they use this notation,
this speaks for notation,
and they are also going
to use some notation that
says notation.
What this rule says
is if A says B speaks
for A then B speaks for A.
So this sounds like sort
of an obvious statement.
Saying that A says
something means
that if we hear A
say something that
means that A told us and we
believed that this, in fact,
was A who told us this thing.
So, in order for A
to say something,
we have to actually believe
this cannot be a message,
for example, that we received
over an untrusted network.
This has to be I sat
next to A in the hall
and A actually said
B speaks for me.
In this case, B might be,
for example, some key.
So A might say my
public key is kA.
If that is true and,
in fact, we believe
that A is the person
who said this to us then
we might be able
to infer from that
that this key kA
actually speaks for A.
This is what the
first rule is and this
is the base case of you
have a trusted communication
channel with
communicating with A
and you can use that
trusted communication
channel to actually build up
some belief about, for example,
a key representing somebody.
Now, the next rule is
one that sort of says
given that we have some belief
about one of these things
like, for example, if we
know that B speaks for A,
we know what A's
public key is and we
overhear B saying that A
says X then we might believe,
in fact, that A says X.
A simple example
of this is suppose
we get a message that has
been signed by this key kA.
If we see that then we might, in
fact, believe that kA actually
says that A says m.
And we might believe
that kA says this
because we believe that
this sort of sign primitive
actually means that if
we see something that
was signed with kA's key
that, in fact, that thing was
generated by kA.
Nobody else could have
generated a signed message
that worked with kA.
We can actually now
receive a message from A
that has been signed using
kA and we can, in fact,
believe that A said something.
Now, the final rule
that we have is
sort of a transitivity
rule which
is a way of expanding this
web of who is related to whom.
This says if B speaks for A
and A speaks for C then what
we're going to believe
is that B speaks for C.
This is just a
transitive relationship.
For example, if we know
that kA speaks for A
and we definitely overhear
B saying A speaks for B,
if B delegates and says that
A can speak for me then we
might believe that key
kA also speaks for B.
This is a simple
transitivity relationship.
The idea with these
rules is that we
going to be able to use them
to actually think about whether
or not we — so we can
anytime we have a
This thing isn't quite
far enough down.
There's a 'then' here
that should say
'then B speaks for C.'
Sorry, that got cut off.
If we have a set of rules
like this then
are going to be able to apply
these rules any time we have
a conversation to decide,
again, whether we actually
trust the people who we
are communicating with.
And you may have noticed,
when I was talking about this,
that there were a
lot of statements
like if we believe that
sign of x, that sign x
nobody can actually
fake this protocol sign X.
We believe that kA —
that signing a message with kA
is as good as — actually —
that nobody could
forge this message that
was signed with kA for example.
If we believe that that
is true then we can say kA
says this thing.
This authentication
logic is full of a lot
of these sort of
like if we believe
this thing is true
kinds of assumptions
that we are going to be making.
Is there a question?
Student: [UNINTELLIGIBLE] of the
third rule but with LaPlace.
Instructor: Sorry, this —
Student: See the bottom part
on the left. I just mean,
I don't know which part of the
example is C.
Instructor: Oh, so in this case
it's — sorry, sorry — you're right.
My example was
kind of confusing.
In this example,
B is actually C.
Sorry, no no no. It's —
Student: k speaks for A.
Instructor: Right. kA is B.
A — right.
It says if B says that — If we
know that B speaks for C —
If we know
that A speaks for B
then we might be willing
to believe that kA actually
speaks for B, given
that kA speaks for A.
So we have this transitivity
kind of a relationship.
Sorry that the notation
was a little bit confusing.
I agree.
The challenge here
is that we want
to try and make, any time
we're using this authentication
logic, in order to
actually determine
that somebody definitely
said something
we are going to have to
make some set of assumptions
about what we trust
and what we believe.
And one of the things
that is important,
any time you are using
this authentication logic,
is to actually make these
assumptions as explicit
as you can.
Let's look at a
set of assumptions
that we are making here.
I said something like when I see
a message that says sign m, kA.
And then I infer from
that that A says m,
assuming that I already know
that kA speaks for A, if I have
something like this and I
make this inference that A
says m given that kA speaks for
A then that's all a sign thing.
I am making a set of
assumptions when I do this.
I am making a set of assumption,
in particular, about what
this sign protocol does.
I am assuming, for example,
that sign is actually
secure in some way.
I am assuming that this
signature is not forgeable,
that somebody else
could not have generated
a signature unless they actually
had access, for example,
to the private key or
to the private key of A.
This signature is not forgeable.
I am also assuming, for
example, that any private keys
are actually private.
I am assuming that, for
example, A hasn't gone out
and broadcasted the private key
to everybody else in the world.
Because if A had done that
then I wouldn't actually
know that A actually said m.
It could have been
anybody who said m.
I would be in trouble
if that were the case.
Any time that I sort of take
this and make this inference
from seeing a sign
like this then that
suggests that I am sort of
making these two assumptions.
And it is not that these
assumptions are wrong or bad,
it is just that it is good to
think about exclusively what
they are.
Assuming that the signature
is forgeable well,
we all know that cryptography
can sometimes be broken.
It is not that cryptography
is totally foolproof,
but we may have a
relatively high confidence
that this cryptography is going
to be difficult for somebody
to break.
And, while assuming that private
keys are actually private,
we might sort of
know A personally
and believe that A is
outright upstanding individual
and we are going to
trust that she hasn't
gone and disseminated her key
everywhere around the world
because that wouldn't
really be in her interest
and we take her to be
a trustworthy person.
This is a bit of a leap of faith
that we are making about this.
But if we believe
those two things then
we can, in fact,
infer that A says
m when we see a message
that is signed with kA.
Let's look at
another example that
works with this sort of
public key cryptography
that we talked about
in this example
with this authentication
protocol here.
Suppose that A tells me
my public key is kA pub
and this is done over
a secure communication
channel like in-person
communication,
I might then infer that kA
pub actually speaks for A.
Now, suppose I
see a message that
has been signed with kA
private. I might say
that then kA private says —
So this is an inference, that
kA private says that A says m.
The question we want to ask
now is should we actually
believe that A said m?
I saw a message, I know
what A's public key is
and I trust A's public key
maybe and I saw this sign thing.
Now I need to think
about do I believe now
that A actually said m given
that I saw a message that
was signed with kA private?
There is something
obviously that we
need to do which is that we
need to verify this message.
Suppose we go and we
run this verify step
on this message and this
verify comes out to be true.
I verify using kA pub
that, in fact, this message
was appropriately signed.
Verify says yes, the signature
on this message checks.
Now should I believe that
that A actually said m?
That depends.
There are a couple
of conditions,
again, sort of set of
assumptions that we are making.
One thing we are clearly doing
is assuming that this crypto
system is secure.
We are also believing that
this verification step actually
gives us, that by taking
something that has been signed
with a private key
and then verifying it
with the public key that
that is as good as A
actually saying something.
One thing clearly
that depends on
is that the crypto
system is secure.
Sorry, I'm just going to
erase some text here
because the bottom got cut off.
So you guys can read.
There are a couple of other
assumptions that we are making.
One thing is that it
definitely, again,
requires that kA private has
actually been kept secret.
And, furthermore, it
requires that A didn't lie
to us about what kA public was.
Because if A had given
us a wrong kA public
then somebody else could
have signed this message
and then we might try
and verify the message
using the lied about
kA public and then we
might be in trouble.
Again, this is similar to
this example with just kA
but just showing how it
works with public and private
key encryption.
It is this case that,
again, we sort of need
to always think about
making our assumptions
as explicit as possible.
And that is really
what it's about.
Deciding that we
trust, for example,
the signature is true
is analogous to deciding
that we have to sort of trust
that we trust the cryptography.
It is possible to apply
this authentication logic
in other environments as well
that aren't necessarily based
on cryptography.
For example, instead of trusting
that the cryptographic system
works, I might trust that
a particular communication
channel is secure.
For example, if I
pick up the telephone
and call you and give
you some message,
you might trust that it's
me because, for example, you
believe that it wouldn't
be possible for somebody
to fake my voice.
And you recognize my
voice because you've
come to lecture so many times.
That would be an example of a
way in which you might decide
that you trust that
something is actually true,
and that would be an
assumption that you're
making about somebody not
being able to fake my voice.
The point of
authentication logic
is that it gives
us a way to kind
of reason about these
kinds of deductions about
whether or not we actually
believe that somebody
said something was true or not.
That is fine.
We still, though,
at least when we're
using public and private
key cryptography,
haven't exactly
answered the question
of how we go about establishing
this initial trust step.
We said we might establish
initial trust by --
There's always sort of
at the bottom of this is we
have to actually physically
overhear somebody say something
over a secure communication
channel, we think.
We have to have some way to
getting this first rule where
A says that my, for example,
public key is something
so we can learn A's public key
so that then we can bootstrap
communication with A.
We haven't yet answered the
question of how we actually
exchange these keys except
for by this one method
that we talked about,
this web of trust method.
There is this question
about establishing
some initial trust.
One way we might
do this is using
this web of trust approach
where I meet a friend,
that friend tells me about some
people who he or she trusts,
and then those friends' friends'
in term know a few people
and eventually we establish
communication with everybody.
There are some computer
systems that work this way.
In particular, there
is a system called
PGP for pretty
good privacy which
is an email-based
privacy encryption
system that works this way.
And there are, in fact,
websites where sort of the idea
is you find somebody else
who has used this system,
you share and you exchange
public keys with them
and then, once you
have a few public keys,
you can sort of build out this
web of trust to everybody else
by trusting people who
your friends trust.
The problem is, one, clearly the
Internet doesn't work this way
so you don't have
this kind of system
that you're using
on the Internet
and, two, these
kinds of systems are
very difficult to
set up and maintain
and there ends up being some
centralized administration.
You end up with having
to have some sort of way,
it becomes very difficult
to actually discriminate
these kinds of public keys
in these kinds of systems.
The way this works is there
is a centralized website.
There is a website for PGP that
is a giant database of keys
and you sort of try and
discover people's keys
by locking this web
of trust, but it
tends to be difficult to use.
Let's talk a little bit
about how this actually works
in the context of the Internet.
Suppose that this browser here
is actually some person, P,
who is sitting in
front of this browser,
and there are some
questions that we might
want to ask when we're thinking
about deciding whether or not
we trust this person,
P. One question
that the Web server might ask is
does W know or trust person P,
or how does it?
This is a commercial
website like Amazon dot com.
Actually, the trust story turns
out to not be that complicated.
Amazon dot com
doesn't really care
that you are who
you claim to be,
as long as you give them
the money that they want.
You can go on and tell them
that you are Oscar the Grouch,
they don't care, as
long as you give them
the money that they want for
whatever it is that you order.
That is all that
matters to them.
So, in fact, what Amazon
does is they don't actually
know who you are exactly but
they might decide that they
trust you because the
credit card number is good
and is verified by the
credit card company.
When they try and charge your
credit card they get the money,
they're happy.
There is this other question,
though, which is that
about how does P trust W?
And the way that this
works on the Internet
is basically like the way
that this authentication
protocol that I have
shown you here works,
this is how SSL works.
And it turns out
to be very subtle.
It can be quite hard to
actually convince yourself
that you should trust a
given website if you actually
start grilling down on it.
There are some issues —
The way that it is going
to decide that it trusts W
is by checking with some
certificate authority.
That is how it works
on the Internet.
And there are some
issues with this,
which is how does
the certificate
authority authenticate W?
How does the
certificate authority
decide what W's key was and how
do they securely exchange keys?
How did the user get
the CA's public key?
And then what if somebody's
private keys are stolen?
For example, W or the
certificate authority's
private keys are stolen.
What I want to do is
just sort of show you,
at a high level, how this
actually works on the Internet.
I thought it might
be instructive just
to see an example of what
is actually going on,
on the Internet, and
to kind of illustrate
how some of these issues
are and are not properly
addressed by the current
sort of SSL-based Internet
architecture.
I have a couple of
websites open here.
I have an Amazon dot
com website and I
have, in this case, an
Apple developer website,
both of which you will notice
have HTTPS URLs associated
with them.
In this browser, if I click on
this little secure icon here,
almost any browser would
have a similar sort
of feature, a little
lock somewhere that when
you are viewing an HTTPS page.
What I see is
something that lists
how it was that
this site actually
decided that this was a secure
site that it should communicate
with.
When that little
lock appears it means
that my browser has
actually decided
that it trusts this site.
We are at the point
where we have already
said we trust this site.
And the reason that we
trust this site, it says,
is because this site is
WWW dot Amazon dot com
and we have this certificate
for this site that
was issued by RSA Data
Security Incorporated.
You might say who is RSA
Data Security Incorporated?
I have never heard
of these people.
I have never exchanged
any information with them.
But they are the
certificate authority.
That is the person
who signed this thing.
I can look and sort
of drill down on this.
And what you will see
is some information
about Amazon dot com.
This is the actual
certificate itself.
This is some information about
the certificate authority,
including information
about what algorithm
the certificate
authority has used
to generate this certificate.
And then now what we have is
this public key information,
the actual public key that
corresponds to Amazon dot com.
The certificate
contains Amazon dot
com's public key
that was encrypted
using the RSA algorithm.
And then there also is some
information, this signature
that goes with this public key.
This is the signature that was
signed by this RSA corporation.
If I go to a different
site like, for example,
this Apple site
over here, we see
that this thing was actually
signed by somebody else.
This certificate is
signed by somebody
called VeriSign Incorporated.
Again, you have no idea who
VeriSign Incorporated is,
but you will notice that these
are two different certificate
authorities.
It is not the case that there
is one master certificate
authority out there
on the Internet that
is in charge of everything.
On a Mac anyway, the same is
true of most other operating
systems, there is
a way that we can
go and look at the actual
list of all the people
who we trust are.
This is sort of an
instructive thing to do.
To go and see who it is
that you actually trust that
is on this computer.
I can click on this
certificate over here.
This is a list of all the
certificates on this machine
that I have and where I
would accept things from.
You can see there are a very
large number of certificates
that this machine has installed.
These are not just certificates
but actual certificate
authorities.
People who I would
actually trust
to sign a communication with
a given site to provide me
with a certificate for,
say, some Web server
that I want to communicate with.
Now the question is so where
did these things come from?
They came from
one of two places.
Either I added them
to the system myself.
In this case, I
have, for example,
an MIT certification authority.
If any of you have ever
used MIT certificates
like when you're
logging onto Websys,
in order to be able
to access that system
you had to add
support for a given
certificate to your browser.
This MIT certification
authority is a certificate
that came from MIT and
this keychain thing
which shows me on
my certificates
has this funny sort
of message that
says this certificate is not
in the trusted root database.
The reason it says that is, this
is a certificate for the MIT
certification authority, I
just got this certificate
for the certification authority
off the Web somewhere.
And I didn't do
something that it
wanted me to do to actually
verify that this, in fact, was
a legitimate certificate from
the certificate authority.
Somebody could have put
this thing on the Web
and said this is a certificate
for the MIT certificate
authority and you should use
it to discover certificates
for anybody who claims to
be coming from MIT dot edu.
They could have lied about it
and then I would be in trouble.
It is possible that this is a
fake certificate for the MIT
certificate authority,
but I sort of
have made this trust, this
assumption that it is not
because I downloaded
it from a website.
And I believe that, in fact,
this is a valid certificate.
The other things you see
here are this large number
of certificates.
For example, one of
the ones that we see,
let's see if we can find
RSA here, this RSA security.
Here I see RSA security.
And this thing actually says
this certificate is valid.
Now there is this
question about where
did RSA security come from?
And the way that this
works is that this browser
and, in this case,
the operating system
itself has actually been shipped
with a bunch of certificates
from a bunch of different
certificate authorities.
And so these have been installed
by the operating system
manufacturer.
And I am saying I
trust Apple to have
gotten the appropriate
certificates
and loaded them appropriately
into the computer.
And any time you download
a browser basically
that browser already has
a set of certificates
for a set of
certificate authorities
already installed in it.
And that is where all of these
base certificate authorities
come from.
You can see that when you
are using one of these things
you have already placed
quite a bit of trust
and made a number of
assumptions about who you trust
and what you should trust
just by using this system.
We have answered
this question now
about where did the user get the
public key for the certificate
authority?
Either they explicitly
added it by downloading it
from a website, for example,
or it came with the browser.
What about this question how
does the certificate authority
authenticate an actual website?
How does Amazon dot com get
a certificate from VeriSign?
The answer to this
turns out to be
that Amazon dot com probably
paid VeriSign some money.
And it is not even
clear you can say that,
but in the case of
VeriSign you are probably
pretty sure that Amazon dot
com paid them some money.
And you can probably go
to the VeriSign website
and see a list of
things that they
claimed to have done in sort of
authenticating Amazon dot com.
They may have forced
Amazon dot com
to present them with some
information that actually
suggests that they are
the company Amazon dot com
or they own some right to
the name Amazon dot com
or that they are incorporated
under the name Amazon dot com.
Basically, the
certificate authority
has some protocol that it
uses to authenticate W.
And we don't know
what that protocol is,
but you're sort of
implicitly trusting
that all these certificate
authorities that Apple has
already approved
for you, in fact,
use some process that we
will be reasonably assured
of guarantying your
privacy or guarantying
that the websites that
you are connecting to
are, in fact, valid
websites that you
should feel comfortable giving
your credit card number to.
You can see that this
is a little bit dicey.
If feels a little bit
like it is not clear
that this is incredibly secure.
And then the last
question is well,
what if your private
keys are stolen?
If your private keys are stolen
in this particular example,
the certificates that you
have from Amazon dot com,
if Amazon dot com's
private keys are stolen
and one of the certificate
authority's private keys
are stolen then
you are in trouble.
These certificates typically
have expiration dates
associated with them, but
these expiration dates
are often like a year
or more into the future.
And so you are going to continue
to trust that certificate
until this certificate
expires in the future when you
will go try and get a new one.
For that whole time that you
trust that certificate somebody
who had access to the private
keys from that certificate
authority or from
that website would
be able to pretend to
be that certificate
authority or that website.
So that might be problematic.
That is sort of the end of this
little discussion about how
certificate authorities work.
I hope you can see that this
authentication logic is sort
of a way that we can start
to get at thinking about what
the trust assumptions
that we are making
are when we are
using these systems.
This wraps up our
discussion of security.
We have one class session last.
And the last class
session is actually
going to be a guest lecturer.
It is going to be
somebody talking
about how law and computers
and technology interact
with each other.
We are kind of
step back and talk
much more about high-level
pictures like policy and law
next time, and hopefully it
will give you a good wrap-up
for the whole class of 6.033.
We will see you next time.
Please come to
class because there
will be questions on the
guest lecturer on the exam,
so you want to make
sure you don't miss it.